some happened this past week that I
think it could inspire you especially
those of you guys I want to recruit the
right run and made the right investor
the right true believer the right
credible source or voice in your
industry to give you an endorsement or
the right partners that 100% believe in
you in the right talent that wants to
run with you I want to share testimony
with you what happened this past week
you know once a year I hold my annual
investor meeting okay an annual carrier
meeting annual partner meeting Thursday
we had a board meeting and in the
following day we had our annual partner
meeting and we hold it at the Crescent
in Dallas I host everybody at the
Capitol girl we take him out my way to
my favorite waiter in the world Steve
was absolutely world-class he hosts us
and we take the bill we don't let these
insurance companies there are multi
multi-billion dollar companies they
could easily take the credit card out
and pay to ten fifteen thousand dollar
bill but we take it and we show a good
time and by the way this is what's so
weird about this meeting that we do
everybody at that table their
competitors meaning they're not you know
they're not collaborating necessarily
it's like I don't want to give you my
ideas on what I'm doing at 2020 and we
got some people that are technology
people pretty much the who's who of the
life insurance or the financial industry
for the most part are in one room
together okay then the following day I
have the meeting and I presented and
what we're gonna be doing in 2020 and
this year was a little bit different
because this year added the four hours
of talk time out of the three hours and
15 minutes of presenting at the end 45
minutes of a dialogue going back and
forth I only spoke 25 minutes this year
because what happened this year was
incredible we cast the division all the
blind spots all our good bad ugly
challenges we face were very transparent
open about what things we struggled with
open about things that we don't know
what we're doing we need their help with
and then we go back and forth and they
give us inside we give them inside but
there's something happened a meeting I'm
in the side and I'm kind of looking
around and afterwards a couple of my
friends jose and math and couple the
guys are asking saying you know how was
this meeting for you I asked him
initially how was a meeting for them
because this was their first time in a
meeting they said but how is it for you
because you know we're going on same Pat
those guys drop your contract now
they're back
those other guys drop your contract
three months after you started a company
ten years ago then they came back now
they're our biggest partners and we love
them and they love us those guys on the
technology side they didn't want to do
business with us we didn't want to do
business with them then they wanted a
big check and then we held back and said
no no we're gonna be your biggest
partner because you're gonna see what
we're gonna do for you we patiently
waited until they came up and say look
we'll do business for you what do you
want to do those guys ended up investing
into the company those guys were worried
about me being a 30 year old CEO with no
four-year degree no two-year degree I've
never ran a financial firm before I
don't know any of this I don't have a
cf1 o CEO or nothin nothin I don't have
any I don't even know how to get an endo
for an insurance company they're looking
at the same well we kind of did into
business with you because we didn't
trust you out what it took to make this
business work and those guys secretly
but you know and banked against us that
these guys yours is not gonna make it
and those guys would say hey don't tell
everybody that you're associating with
us and that we're sitting in the room
today and the former CEO and chairman of
a major organization that everybody in
the insurance industry pays $20,000 here
to be a member of the former CEO and
chairman is sitting on our board now and
the press release just went out Bob
sitting on our board what happened here
so in that moment it's very easy for
somebody to say look Who I am
look at this screw everybody it's
because of us that this is what happened
no it took patience to win them over
it took patience to win people over I
don't blame them for not initially
trusting to do business with us I don't
blame them I may have the same feeling
about somebody if I was them they have a
lot more to lose than I do this is why
some of the companies that banked on us
early I really have a lot of value and
admiration for them because I don't even
know if I would do it because if I knew
about pbd how much he knew about running
a company I probably also wouldn't do
business with Peabody ten years ago the
30 year old CEO
vd yeah no clue what you do what's the
moral of the story here with this
everyone sitting there is like oh my
gosh we're gonna get so much business
from this company they're gonna write a
hundred and some thousand policies and
we're gonna get this yes this is why I
said at the beginning to you
aggressively patient you know it's funny
over the years I've done business with a
lot of people that took me seven years
to do business with two years to do
business with six months to do business
with five years ten years even 15 years
until they eventually do business with
me and you know what happens sometimes I
look at them sometimes and they'll say
yeah I just don't know if this is
something that we can do together and
I'm like it I'm gonna see ah one of two
things is gonna happen
what's that one I'm going to find
somebody and we're gonna run with that
person you know it's the other thing I
tell myself and I tell them maybe in the
next 6 12 24 36 months from now we're
gonna do business together but maybe not
right now why because I haven't learned
my street credit yet totally get it but
be patient you'll see what happened see
that mindset comes from you having to
earn it earn it
then you call the shots not the other
way around
not the other way around you want the
best running mates you want the best
investors you want the best advisors you
want the best endorsements you want the
highest level of credibility in a
marketplace you want your enemies to
become your frenemies and eventually
become your allies and even become your
best allies you got to go earn it I had
to earn it yes sometimes they say stuff
behind your back yes sometimes in front
your face they'll tell you how amazing
you're on the moment they walk and they
go whisper to you guys other guys saying
this guy's gonna go out of business and
make six months and then it comes back
to me yes I heard all of this stuff but
I love it because I understand in this
game of business I gotta go
earn it even when I was afraid even when
I was insecure even when I was about to
throw in the towel and I was worried
whether I had the goodies or not even in
those moments that's why when you win it
feels that good and when you look at
those people's faces in their eyes you
know how they look at you they don't say
anything but here's what their I say
props like a louder speak for you good
for you that's what they say no words
but the ice is everything everything in
that moment when you experience that all
the money in the world cannot replace
that that's why so many kids of
billionaires die to experience how some
people looked at their father who made
the money work this tail off
they can't experience that because they
gotta go earn it themselves they gotta
go earn it themselves all the money in
the world cannot buy you that look that
look can only be earned okay so if you
want that you're in your early 20s you
want everybody realize how special you
are you want everybody realize how
amazing you are how big you're going to
be go earn it go earn it so you no
longer have to make a case for it
because the marketplace makes the case
for you you do that the rest is history
having said that if you haven't
subscribed to the channel do so if you
got anything you took away from this
anything you took away from this or it
gives you the guts to want to make new
commitments comment below with your
commitments for 2020 what you're gonna
do to go out there and earn it having
said that have a killer week everybody
take care bye bye